there's benefits in honoring your native
language and also your native culture
and then you become a more joyful
learner and then you have a better
chance to succeed
Sarah Hansen in this episode Our Guest
is Michelle DeGraff
the co-founder and co-director of the
MIT Haiti initiative which promotes the
use of Haitian Creole in Haitian schools
he's also the instructor of the newly
revised course on ocw
24908 Creole languages and Caribbean
identities
we actually spoke with Michelle back in
season one and he talked about
connecting language to issues of culture
identity and Power
in this episode we're taking a deeper
look at some of these themes and how he
navigates them with his students but for
those unfamiliar with Michelle's work
and presence let's start at the
beginning the origins of a Linguistics
professor
I really became a linguist by accident
my first career was as a computer
scientist
and I got a wonderful job which I never
forget at ATT belab as an intern as an
undergraduate and this is where for the
first time I got to understand that
language is really a system of
computation where you connect
sounds or in the case of sign languages
where you connect gestures with
information with meanings and before I
had no clue that that's what defined
language and before that for the first
20 years of my life I had never
considered my native language
Haitian Creole which we call Creole in
Haiti I've never thought of it as a real
language but I always thought that
Creole was broken French was corrected
French was bad French that's what I was
told as a child
so that moment at hntb Labs it dawned on
me that for the first 18 years of my
education I had been lied to I've been
lied to
at home by my parents because she loved
me very much so it was a lie
rooted in love then I was lied to by my
teachers from age three four to age 18
in fact back in school I wasn't allowed
to speak my native language in fact I
was finished for speaking it
so then at the labs it was a moment of
epiphany I actually remember when I
realized that physically it was a
disturbance you know to think oh gosh
why is it that for all these years I
never thought of my native language of
the full language and that's when I I
decided to learn more about Linguistics
learn more about what makes a language
language so back that Labs I was
actually writing programs for Computer
Sciences and for language trying to
create the first versions of things like
Siri or Alexa doing text to speech
synthesis and trying to understand
natural language with computers so I
turned out with the computers that
taught me about language eventually
of re-examining childhood experience
experiences and the ways we learn about
identity are woven into the course
material of 24 908 Creole languages and
Caribbean identities
in the course Michelle asks the students
to examine themselves and the world
around them in profound and meaningful
ways
the key part that they learn to learn or
they learn to uncover is the basic
fundamental role that language plays in
how they form their own identity and how
language structures social relations the
way they view others and the way others
view them and what they learn really
that I find to be fundamental is the
hidden role that language often plays in
the creation and transition of power
power in terms of opportunities to
become successful students opportunities
to get good jobs opportunities to even
find a mate in all these relations
language plays such a key fundamental
role that's often hidden so what they
learn to do is to make the hidden
visible
you see and for them to do that they
have to dig deep in their own
biographies in their own
attitudes about people because whatever
attitudes we have about language it's
not just about language it's really
about other human beings other social
groupings or the ethnicities other even
religions other countries
[Music]
through Colonial lenses and that can
also reveal so much about the human
beings held in that history in the case
of colonized Nations like Haiti and the
Sim is true for most of the Caribbean is
true for Native Americans in the US it's
true for Palestinians it's true for
Africans in many parts of Africa
the way history is written it's often
written from the perspective of the
colonizers even in a country like Haiti
we've been independent since 1804 but my
history book
was so Colonial to Independence was
bragged about was honored but if you
read between the lines even from the
very preface your Haitian child is
taught to despise their own ancestors a
history book teaches us to Revere to
adore the colonizers including someone
like bartolome De Las Casas who was one
of the very early architects of the
slave trade a history book right in the
preface teaches that Las Casas is to be
revealed as a hero I think this is
perhaps the most striking example of how
even an independent country like Haiti
or history books are so thoroughly
Colonial but one way to get out of it is
to look at language in the case of Haiti
Haitian Creole to understand how from
the very beginning of Haiti's history
the Africans resisted this
dehumanization
as you might expect sometimes these
conversations can be intense for
students I asked Michelle about how he
approaches subjects that directly deal
with the cascading effects and Trauma of
colonialism
it's class its session is really it's
both reaffirming but it can make us feel
so fragile because I went through this
this experience when I was in my early
20s realizing that how history
colonialism
actually even Theory
I've played such a major role in the way
I look at myself
it's a very challenging position to be
in and I can tell you that in our class
there's been tears shed
[Music]
Michelle explained that one commonly
difficult subject for students is
examining the processes of assimilation
so many of the stories students confront
in this class involve exploring the
trauma of assimilation especially when
it leads to devaluing or even abandoning
their cultural heritage
children of immigrants in the U.S
because of social pressure because of
this push to assimilate the parents
really give up on the ancestral
languages and cultures and then when the
students when they go to college like in
this case you know when they take my
course and then they understand the
roots of this pressure to assimilate
then they really see themselves as
victims and they realize the loss
because there's so much loss in not
having kept your ancestral language and
and I'm as a parent
I I know it because I know how difficult
it is in the case of my own children to
keep Asian clearly alive in the
household and because this again even as
a linguist there is so much pressure
that you have to struggle to make sure
that your children can keep speaking in
a world where
is a view that's been useful so it takes
lots of efforts and I'm your linguist
I know that
speaking honoring your native language
in a way would prevent you from learning
a second language or a third language or
a fourth language is not either or
what's key is to recognize that your
native language is Haitian Creole is a
basic tool to build from foundations to
learn science and math and all other
types of knowledge including second
languages right so you can have it all
once you realize that there is no need
to exclude on the contrary there is
benefit in honoring your native language
to use it as a tool to learn
other things like French for example you
see and we have data that confirm it not
just in Haiti but also in Hawaii in
Africa in fact they are very robust data
that you're for example in Hawaii
children who are immersed in Hawaiian
actually succeed in becoming better
speakers of English you see so it's not
either or the contrary there's benefit
in honoring your native language and
also your native culture and then you
become a more joyful learner and then
you have a better chance to succeed
one of the unique aspects of this class
is how it draws on students personal
experiences to teach about cultural
phenomena like the origins of linguistic
power structures
so to get some deeper insight about the
class we spoke with two of Michelle's
students
my name is Diana Ferguson I am currently
a rising Junior at MIT with the intended
major in the physical sciences and I was
a student of 24 908 in the spring 2022
semester
presently in my homeland Saint Vincent
and the Grenadines it is a 33 island
nation in the Southern Caribbean
I enrolled in
24908 as being a Caribbean National and
having lived in the Caribbean all my
life I was very interested in an outside
perspective of the Caribbean in terms of
its identities and its Creole languages
the class really made me think very
differently about the world every week
someone in the class is in charge of
leading a discussion based on the
assigned reading for that week and you
had to connect your reading to your
experience and expand on something that
resonated with you in the reading so I
like to say that we are presenting our
world to each other
so my difficulty was that I had to share
my world with persons who have not
experienced it and rightly so because
each person has a different outlook on
the world so my running theme was always
to make my classmates understand my
world so that when we discuss things
they would be able to see why and how I
said things honest to things the way
that I did
um so you wrote this really great
article Linguistics and economics in the
Caribbean who speaks Creole I'm
wondering could you tell us what your
article was about
the article is entitled Linguistics and
economics in the Caribbean who speaks
Creole examines the reasons why Creole
languages have been devalued and it
investigates this from a socio-economic
perspective where persons who view
themselves as of a class or wealthy tend
to speak and acrylic which is a variety
of Creole closer to the colonizing
Nations language while those of lower
socioeconomic status speak basilect
which is a variety of Creole furthest
from the colonizing Nations language
Caribbean Nationals perpetuate the
disuse of Creole as we have been
conditioned really since the period of
slavery and taught that being able to
speak a standard language of foods or
guarantees success and proves
intelligence
not everyone goes from a course
assignment to publishing for the public
so I'm curious how you made that
transition
I think we would have to thank Professor
DeGraff for that because I wrote this
piece with no intention of publishing it
for me it was just a subset of a project
that I had been working on and I was
just exploring the ideas and researching
about Linguistics and the Caribbean but
Professor the graph spoke to me about
publishing it and he gave me some time
to think about it the deciding factor
was that I saw it as a way that
Caribbean persons or even the world in
general could be made more aware of
themselves and this could have an impact
for further Generations
overall I want the article to encourage
Caribbean persons to be proud of their
Creole languages and I want to encourage
them to be able to speak Creole
and the standard language as I opined
that doing this gives one different ways
of interpreting the world
the other student we spoke with got just
as much out of Michelle's class even
though she grew up in a very different
part of the world
my name is Vivian sansoor and I was born
in Jerusalem I grew up in Palestine
and spoke Arabic that's my native
language
I grew up in a small little village
called beijala it's in the Bethlehem
District
and for me language
could mean life or death at time
I grew up under Israeli military
occupation so if I was identified at a
checkpoint and I didn't understand what
the soldiers said in Hebrew if he said
come and I left or if he said go and I
came
it could mean literally the death of me
many Palestinians have died at
checkpoints
Vivian shared how Michelle was able to
create a space that was safe for
students to honestly share their
personal experiences of their world and
what that did for her is the only
student in the class not of Caribbean
heritage
the first thing he did was actually
bring himself to the table and that in
itself opened
our hearts to see that you know whatever
we bring to the table is gonna be safe
when someone shares their vulnerability
it allows you to feel safe to do the
same and he offered that generosity not
knowing who's in the class and I think
he engage in a very gentle yet gradual
process of us developing slowly trust
with each other to the point where by
the end of the class like our
presentations I feel were deeply
personal and quite profound I think
we were able to understand our personal
experiences within the context of a
political structure in the world
I mean one of Michelle's powerful
approaches is that while the class is
about the Caribbean he does a great job
of weaving in how the Caribbean relates
to other things and other places and
what was happening in the world and that
big vision is I think urgent in our
times and that's part of why I connected
so much to the class he didn't think it
was super strange that a Palestinian
woman wants to learn about the Haitian
revolution he found ways to weave it
into my own experience and it allowed
him I think to learn about me so I felt
that his curiosity about who we are not
just me I mean every single person in
the class allowed us to feel seen and to
feel that who we are and how we see the
world matters and that is significant
because then you're motivated to
actually discover and become more
curious about the other rather than just
dismiss other people's experience as
something that you can't relate to
each time you teach that course you have
a different group of students it's
almost impossible to predict
how to make sure that each student is
going to feel safe enough in the course
so I start with having the students fill
out a linguistic autobiography for them
to learn to reflect on
how to socialize into certain beliefs
about what they speak what the parents
speak what others in the community speak
for them to start becoming aware
of the role that language plays in the
socialization and that's a very delicate
exercise because you have to start
asking themselves questions about what
they believe about themselves through
language
I tell them about my own biography I'm
very honest about the fact that for a
good chunk of my life I was really in a
state of mental slavery without being
aware of it you see but then once I
bring that up some students feel free to
also describe their own experience
having these attitudes that are very
much prejudicial against certain
varieties of languages including
sometimes their own or their parents but
others I can see you know they breathe
themselves you know some of them do not
feel safe enough to open up and to share
this kind of experiences and I tell them
look when you present in this class I
don't want you to just summarize the
readings you have to take the readings
and see how they apply to you to your
community to your sometimes your parents
you know if the parents you know grew up
in the Caribbean or grew up say yes
where where there was this strict
language hierarchies you want to apply
those readings to those familiar cases
and some of them are comfortable doing
it after a bit but you can see that
others resist it throughout and I think
it's because it involves certain skills
that I might not have having to do with
say Psychotherapy because someone said
it's really getting deep into the ways
you were made to think of yourself as
human being
so in so that can be very challenging
but what I find is that in many cases
actually maybe in most cases
there's a sense of Liberation it's very
cathodic to become aware of these
patterns in your own life
Michelle shared with me how cultural
conceptions about Haiti are deeply
fraught due in part to the way its
history has been told
so the New York Times I don't know if
you've seen it the other recent series
that came out and the Articles were
published in English and for the very
first time for the New York Times in
Haitian Creole
and also in French and the idiotical is
about the ransom that the French forced
on Haiti for friends to recognize
Haiti's Independence that was back in
1825 the French engineered this really
double that they imposed a ransom of
150 million francs until they brought
these boats on the coast of Haiti they
say we're going to bomb you out
if you don't agree to Ping back this
amount
he said to pay to former sleeve holders
for the loss of the property because of
Haiti becoming independent this is the
only time in the history of the world
that a nation that became independent
after winning the war of independence
after freeing themselves had to pay
current code reparations to the
slaveholders who were defeated by the
war
and that amount in today's dollars is
worth 21 billion plus and an economists
have done very simulations to show that
with that so-called that he had to pay
it would have never been able to develop
as a normal Nation foreign
[Music]
in my course I've been teaching it for
decades now so I knew about this but
what the New York Times did was to
document it very closely in terms of how
much exactly Haiti paid to the French
and where that money go and then of
course the US in 1915 also came to Haiti
and further ravaged his own finances by
basically stealing money from Haitian
Banks so it's a really ugly story but
one major Gap in the New York Times
story is the failure to analyze the
cultural and intellectual aspect of the
ransom so in fact there's another Ransom
that hit had to pay that's the cultural
linguistic Ransom because as the French
impose this quote-unquote debt on Haiti
the also Force Hisense to adopt estate
altercation based on the French language
so in 1860 there was a famous contract
sign that forced Haiti to accept
teachers from French Catholic orders and
those teachers the mission was to impose
French and French values on the Haitian
school system my history book is a
result of this agreement with the fans
you see so Haiti has also been held
Ransom through language and this is
another factor that explains why hate
has been so impoverished from the very
beginning of its history
this rule can be so hidden and so
invisible that even if a detailed
account of the French in Haiti still
fails to analyze that aspect of
neocolism so let's stop saying that
quote-unquote Haiti is the poorest
country of the Western Hemisphere
instead let's understand why it's so
poor let's understand the roots of
Haiti's misery and the rules of it is
misery is in the ways that France and
the US have ravaged atheist finances in
abominable ways
since recording this MS published an
essay in the New York Times addressing
this Gap we'll put a link to his essay
in the show notes
before we end the episode Michelle had
something he wanted to share in Haitian
Creole just to give the English speakers
the sense of what I'm going to say I'm
going to actually really Reef on the
theme of black lives matter if black
lives matter then our languages as black
people also matter
um
foreign
[Music]
if you're interested in teaching or
learning with materials from the updated
version of 24908 Creole languages and
Caribbean identities please visit our
website at
ocw.mit.edu you'll find all the
materials there and as always they are
free and open
you can help others find the materials
too by subscribing to the podcast and
leaving us a rating and review
if you enjoyed this episode you might
also want to check out our season 1
episode with Michelle unpacking
misconceptions about language and
identities
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT opencourseware
MIT chalk radio's producers include
myself Brett patchy and Dave leshansky
the show notes for this episode were
written by Peter Chipman
Peter also built the updated course on
our site